welcome to mozy nation in this video i'm
going to be sharing with you the three
most important lines that you need to
draw in your business that you probably
are not and i want to show you some
different uh combinations of these lines
and how dramatically it will impact how
much money you make and ultimately the
value of the company that you ultimately
build
so if you don't know my name is my name
is alex from mozilla and acquisition.com
we do about 85 million a year and i have
nothing to sell you this is a
rona-sponsored episode so if i'm less
chipper than normal um that is why uh we
thank our sponsors as always and so
these are the three lines that i think
everyone needs to understand all right
so line number one right here i'm gonna
make sure that you guess so if you can
guess right now which each of these
lines are going to represent you have
price
you have value and you have cost of
goods
all right so every line has every
business has these three lines within
everything that they sell you have how
much you sell it for you have how much
value the person gets
and you have what it costs you and what
i want to show you is the mental
framework and the interplay between
these things and how dramatically it can
shift your business
so this is the value line this is what
they are getting this is the price line
this is how much you charge this is the
cost of goods
line which is how much it costs you to
fulfill on this value right right okay
so here's where it gets kind of cool
if we move our price up
see how little value we have here
this means that we have a low customer
surplus
customer surplus is the excess between
what they pay and what they get
the higher the surplus the greater the
distance between these two things here
the more value they will perceive that
they have gotten from your services the
bigger this discrepancy is
the more viral your business will be
imagine
there was a day years and years ago
where you could have access to
everything in the entire blockbuster
store
on demand from the comfort of your home
and you could do it for less than it
cost to do a new release
and uh
to run a new release wouldn't that be
amazing well they did create that and
that was called netflix
and so what they did was they priced it
so low
but their cost of goods was still lower
because the cost of the incremental cost
of adding a single customer
was is basically nothing right and so
their gross margins here
is still very high because for them they
can still
lower these things even more and so what
i'm telling you at the end of this video
is that the trick to how you actually
can build a fortune simply understanding
the interplay between these three lines
if i have one takeaway for everybody
who's watching this is that if you can
think about your business just using
these three lines then you will be able
to build a fortune if we have here
our cost of goods at the bottom
and
we
raise this all the way to here
and we have
a you know a ton of customer surplus
what kind of business is this this is
going to be a business that probably
doesn't need to market very much this is
going to be a business that is probably
operationally difficult probably a
service-based business and probably runs
on very thin margins many businesses run
like this these are a lot of old school
businesses that grow consistently every
year by you know 10 15 per year and they
don't have a ton of money to reinvest in
resources they're very operationally
efficient in order to run a business
like this
that's business scenario one let's see
if you can guess what type of business
this would be
so
this
is most of your generic mom-and-pop
businesses decent margin let's say this
is the baseline here sorry there's our
baseline
decent margins here decent margins
decent value just kind of another
run-of-the-mill business um nothing
underwhelming or overwhelming about this
business and this is what most small
businesses operate like
so let me tell you what type of business
i would like to try and create my goal
is always to find a way
to provide something that's excessively
valuable
they cost me almost nothing to make
unique expensive sticky year for those
of you know guys who uh know that
channel it's one or one of that video
it's my favorites
i want something that costs almost
nothing provides tremendous value and
creates a big customer surplus and
here's what's crazy
the bigger you do this discrepancy
the more viral your business will become
for me as i feel like i've aged in
entrepreneurial doggy years
the more i strive for this than anything
else
because if you conquer this piece you
conquer the customer surplus in terms of
how much value they are getting for what
they are paying then
you will have an infinitely scalable
business because you will have a
quadratic way of expanding which is
through word of mouth which is the
antithesis of what everyone in the
marketing world will tell you but the
goal should always be to have a business
that grows on word of mouth the problem
is most people don't have enough word of
mouth because this surplus is not big
enough
if you have the surplus big enough and
you go from good to great and great to
so good that people cannot help but tell
their friends about you remarkable or
remark worthy that is how good it is
then you will have more customers than
you know what to do with and your cost
of acquisition will be zero and your
your business will grow quadratically
not linearly
that is the difference between making
money and building a fortune and i
thought of this visual with the three
lines and i just thought it was really
telling and so i thought i would keep
this short in the spirit of rona to show
you this
but if you can think through how you're
providing value and really focus because
the things that you can control you can
control all three of these variables but
when i'm trying to diagnose a problem
that i want to solve as an entrepreneur
i think how can i provide the most value
step one step two
how can i lower my cost of goods sold to
a crazy degree
and then once i know how i can lower my
cost of goods sold to a crazy degree i'd
rather have something that cost me a
penny
that i can sell for 10 cents
that has the value of 10 and if you have
that kind of value that you're able to
deliver you will make a
literal f ton of money and so i think
this is a useful framework you can plot
your own business you can probably plot
your competitors business using this
simple framework and i thought i would
give it to you because it's one of the
tools that i use when i'm thinking
through how valuable an enterprise could
potentially be and how i can move these
lines around to create value create
margin and ultimately take home the most
money and help the most people just like
everything that we do
hopefully the price that you paid was
the time the value that you got was
hopefully a framework that you can use
to apply to your business and the cost
of goods sold for me is the time that it
takes me to do this and the the many
failures and lessons i've learned and
suffered the hard costs of failure to
make these little uh frameworks for you
so anyways mosey nation i love you guys
uh the reason i make this uh stuff is
because a lot of people are broke and i
don't want you to be one of them as
always i have nothing to sell you keep
being awesome if you enjoyed this hit
subscribe if you didn't love either way
catch you guys next video bye